and how about the one that is
responsible for most of the suicide
bombings I'm a fool because I am
Islamophobic yeah so this idea of you
know suicide bombings and suicide
killings and all that it's important
again to understand this in context and
understand you know where did this start
what is the history behind it and why do
people do it and where is the connection
between Islam there's always is somehow
this connection between Islam and
suicide bombing that's what's in the
minds of many people because that's what
they consume in mainstream media
unfortunately let's let's take a look at
some facts okay the first recorded
suicide attack that we know of as as
human beings as as researchers was
actually done by Christian Crusaders
against Muslims so there was a group of
Crusaders who actually sunk their own
ship so they could that they could
actually result in 10 times the deaths
of Muslims on that you know for the
expedition right so this is the first
incident right this is it classical then
you fast-forward to like the modern era
you find the first suicide bombing
modern suicide bombing that's taking
place in st. Petersburg right in 18
let's see what's the year I got 1881
where they killed the Czar basically the
guy was not a Muslim this was not a
Muslim suicide bombing and suicide
bombings continue it continues and it
continues with kamikazes so in war you
got the Japanese and what they're doing
is many Japanese are volunteering
themselves to get in airplanes and they
go and they crash you know bombs into
certain you know ships insisting those
ships the Germans are practicing the
same type of suicide bombing techniques
during the battle for Berlin against the
Russians so they're going and they're
trying to destroy the bridges that are
coming they're sacrificing their own
lives for a military purpose and then
what really happened is there really
wasn't much suicide bombing during the
Cold War period that's really
interesting the reason why there and
this is important for everyone to
understand specifically Joe is that the
reason why there wasn't suicide bombing
during the Cold War period is because
the superpowers of the US and Russia
Soviet Union they're equipping these
little countries that are fighting with
each other right
they're equipping them with a lot of
weapons when you have a lot of
pins to fight other people back with you
don't need suicide-bombing
so then what happened was is that we
don't see much during the Cold War the
next instance of suicide bombing that we
start seeing is in Lebanon so in Lebanon
when Israel goes and occupies Lebanon in
the early 80s you get a movement of
people who cannot fight back against
superior military technology that Israel
has so they start getting this idea of
let's start doing the suicide bombings
what's really interesting and this is
how suicide bombing became prevalent in
modern society today it started in
Lebanon particularly and what's really
interesting is 77 percent of the people
who were engaging in suicide bombings in
Lebanon they were communists or
socialists they were not doing it for
Islamic reasons they were not doing it
because you know they're inspired to do
for some Muslim cause or something like
that and what's more interesting is 8
percent of them were Christian as well
right so this is not a religious thing
this is a secular thing meaning in the
sense that it's something that people
are doing because they have no other
military option to carry out anything
and then when people saw that Israel
actually backed out of Lebanon they say
oh well it looks like suicide bombings
potentially working and we don't have
any resources to fight back we should do
something along these lines right so now
somehow you know what's going on in the
world today is whenever you find a group
of people it doesn't matter if it's the
Tamil Tigers in Sri Lanka who are not
religious this is not a Muslim group
they have nothing to do with Islam at
all they were conducting suicide
bombings against the government so that
they could get their own Tamil region
right why are they doing this this is a
way for people who don't have many
resources to fight back for whatever
cause they're fighting for so when
you're deciding what who's a terrorist
and what's a terrorist and who's
fighting and who's suicide bombing the
first thing gotta ask yourself is is
this cause justified what they're
fighting for are they freedom fighters
are they terrorists the second the
second thing is do they have the ability
to fight or they don't have the ability
to fight back if they don't have any
weapons and they're being oppressed or
they have no resources whatsoever then
yeah they might be willing to utilize
their bodies what is all of this have to
do with Islam absolutely nothing there
is absolutely nothing can
with the religion of Islam that's saying
you should go and use yourself as a
vicar body as a way of going and you
know targeting a specific bomb an
individual or going and you know killing
innocent civilians or all the other
things that are somehow connected or
tied to suicide bombing so this idea of
what Islam is responsible for suicide
bombing it's just another another one of
those you know just fake misleading
propaganda statements that just keeps
being thrown out there and it kind of
takes away the context of what is the
political circumstance going on in that
specific area in that country where we
need to analyze is this struggle just or
unjust killing of innocent civilians is
never just it's never allowed in Islam
but that's not even when people say
suicide bomb they aren't even talking
about that
they have a problem with this idea of
suicide and bombing and killing or
whatever it is this is a military thing
it's a political thing in order for this
to take place there needs to be a
political context that's what needs to
be kept in mind and who I see who
substantiate academics they don't bring
them on mainstream media because it only
doesn't support the narrative no and it
would educate the public to you know the
the awareness of really what's going on
in these air in these areas of the world
that Robert Pape you know the terrorist
expert
yeah delays over a thousand different
terrorist attacks to date and he talks
about a this has little to nothing to do
with Islam or religion a lot of times he
said that many of these are secularists
he says and people are about to do a
suicide attack and now they're gonna
face death and all of a sudden they
become religious right right because
that's it now people find God at the end
all right and now they cling on to it
but in reality it's because they want
the occupying force out of there and
like you're saying they have no other
means and again did anything to do with
Islam now no it's it's all political
politically it's problems exactly with
the terrorist expert dr. Roberts every
terrorist expert says that you know what
there's a political you know objective
that's there you need to justify that
objective you're gonna you're gonna
justify it either with nationalism a
Nazi Party neo-nazi whatever it is
you're gonna justify it with some
religion that you practice you're gonna
justify
with your superiority of your race you
need to justify the political objective
some people will use religion to justify
it some people will use nationalism some
people will use race they'll use other
metal factors if there's no political
objective then there's not gonna be any
terrorism my opinion is injustice
humiliation oppression that is are the
most common causes some people claim
that religion motivates terrorists
however the academic research of dr.
Robert Pape has proved the claim to be
false what I did is I collected the
first complete database of every suicide
terrorist attack around the world since
1980 the first version of this database
was published a few years ago and I went
from 1980 to 2003 I think of that as
like the pre Iraq database and then the
second version from 2004 on think of
that is the data that's happened since
Iraq and what the data shows quite
clearly is that the principal cause of
suicide terrorism is foreign occupation
in that period from 1980 to 2003 there
were 315 completed suicide terrorist
attacks by 462 suicide terrorists who
actually killed themselves and I mean
attempts these are people who actually
killed themselves the world leader
during that 24 year period was not an
Islamic group at all there are the Tamil
Tigers in Sri Lanka the Tamil Tigers are
a Marxist group a secular group a Hindu
group in fact over half of those 462
suicide attackers were purely secular
because you see many Muslims suicide
terrorist groups are also purely secular
such as the PKK in Turkey the PKK in
Turkey which did numerous suicide
attacks in the 1990s is again a Marxist
read anti religious suicide terrorist
group because you see if Islam as sort
of a radical religion or if it were just
radical
doing this than what you would expect is
sort of this thin veneer of suicide
attack kind of scattered all around the
world you would expect that oh there's
1.4 billion Muslims you know there's
this teeny tiny fringe of Muslims kind
of everywhere who'd be willing to do
suicide attack but that's not the way
the data looks it's really concentrated
and it's really concentrated in
occupations